♪ C'est ma fête
C'est ma fête à moi, moi ♪
(clap)
- Non, mais avant de commencer
l'entrevue, est-ce que vous vous
des... dans le miroir comme ça?
(rire)
- Un peu, ouais.
- Sérieusement?nsnsnsnsnsnsnsns,
gymnastique faciale?PIERRE-YVES,
humoriste, animateur et comédien
Non mais sans farce, quand
je préparen n personnage,
mettons, je me regarde dans le
miroir pour voir qu'est-ce
qui est le plus efficace.
- OKPaParce que là,
je m'attendais aussi pour
l'entrevue que vous courriez ê s
toujours comme ça dans vos
shshows, là. Ça va-tu arriver là
pendant l'entrevue?
- Je pense pas, non.
- Bien, parce que ce serait
lourd si j'étais de même
dans la vraie vie, hein?
- Ouin, non. q q q q q q q q q .
- Vous êtes pas comme ça
dans la vraie vie?
- Pas du tout.
- Calme?oui, t'as pas ressenti e
j'étais un peu plus...
- Quand jeuiuis allé vous
chercher en bas dans la
réception, oui, vraiment calme.
Je me disais : Coudonc, il est
- Je suis juste un être humain
normal, t'sais.
- - Sérieusement?
(éclats de rire)
Non mais est-ce que Pierre-Yves
Roy-Desmarais c'est
- Ah oui! Bien oui,
bien sûr, je suis pas plate,
je suis juste normal, je pense.
- Ouin?
- Je pense que
je suis rcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcrcr,
j'ai parlé à vos collègues
humorist p puis ils me disent :
"Oui, Pierre-Yves Roy-Desmarais,
il est drôle, puis il est très,
trènsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsns,
il est pas..."- Ils disent-tu p?
- Non, ils ne disent pas plate,
mais ils disent : "T'sais,
t'sais, dans un party, il ne
montera pas sur la table, là".
- Non, non, exact.
- OK.
- C'est ça je pense
- Normal, mais très drôle
sur scène.
- Oui.
- Quand même. Et modeste!
(rire)
(rires)
- On commence-tu l'entrevue?
- Oui, on va faire ça.
- On va être sérieux, là.
(clap)
- Après vos chansons
d'ouverture du Bye B 2 2020
et du Bye Bye 2021, là,
vous avez un rôle principal
da
C'est quand même un rêve de
petit gars qui devient réalité?
- Bien, mets-en, c'est vraiment
un rêve, en fait, de toujours.
comédie sous toutes ses formes,
en passant par q q q q q q q q s
grosse tribune de sketchs
comiques au Québec que le
Bye Bye. Fait que je les ai pas
mal to
je me souviens. Euh...
Oui, fait que c'est vraiment
un beau trip, là.
Enchanté, jm'm'appelle
Pierre-Yves, je vais faire une
couple de jokes à l'Olympia.
pour jour, j'ai assisté à
la pmièmière médiatique de
votre premier spectacle solo
"Joke, chapeau, maman, magie,???
- Tu l'as eu d'une shot.
- Boum! Et à la fin, je vous ai
vu, j'étais quand même près,
je vous ai vu en larmes.
- Oui.
- Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé?
- Bien, c'est vraititititititit.
c'était pas juste deux ans
de rodage ou de... c'est
vraiment l'aboutissement
de... de..entre guillemets. J'a.
je sais que j'avais juste 27
à l'époque, mais ça reste que
de... de faire de l'humour,
de faire dststand-up,
d'être sur scène,
d'avoir mon propre show.
Puis je m'en suis rendu compte
à ce moment-là, tu sais,
que ça f
ces années-là que je concentrais
toutes mes énergies vers une
affaire, puis c'était lancer
ce show-là en espérant
Parce que je vous en fais voir
de toutes les couleurs!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le personnage Pierre-Yves'e'et
l'expression dans le visage.Voue
nationale de l'humour en 2017.
À quel moment vous l'avez complt
déjanté? Parce qu'on a vraiment
l'impression que votre visage
se transforme de gag en gag.
- Ah, bien crime, c'susususususu
compte euh... en fait,
j'ai toujours su que j'aimais
faire de l'humour physique,
je pense, mas s s s s s s s s ss
comme rendu compte
pendant la pandémie.
Il a fallu que j'arrête
de
pour me rendre compte que...
vraiment, je pouvais
communiquer des affair p p p p s
à un niveau supplémentaire
juste avec la face ou les
mimiques. C'est vraiment en
me filmant, fait
lala pandémie, les chansonnette,
le fait d'être obligé
de se filmer,i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-.
♪ C'est pas sa faute
C'est celle du iPad ♪ v v v v vt
un cadeau pour la fin de
votre tournée en 2023 :
le Centre Bell.
- Oui! C'e
Bien t'sais, pour toi qui as vu
le show, qui est très énergique,
qui a beaucoup... on utilise
la scène au complet,
Bien, on dirait que la place
ultime où faire vivre ce
show-là, c'est au Cens s s s s .
Il n'y a pas plus rock
que le stage du Centre Bell.
Fait que ça s'appelle
"Pierre-Yves Rtrtrtrtrtrtrtrtrt.
Donc en fait, la meilleure joke,
elle n'était pas dans mon show.
La meilleure joke n'est pas
de moi
a été trouvée par hasard
par un scientifique
il y a plusieurs années,
Et puis, donc, j'ai mis
la main dessus, puis
je la livre une fois.
- Le 27 juillet au Centre Bell.
- À la fin du show?
- À la toute fin du spectacle.
- Pierre-Yves Roy-Desmarais,
- Merci à toi.
♪ Je dis merci ♪
pour les pet
♪ Qui ont l'air de rien
de nos héros du quotidien ♪
♪ Je dis merci